a shining a spotlight on talent and
adults with disabilities yeah the 11th
annual Ovation variety shows out as that
Opportunity Village Thursday Lauren
negrady though was there this morning
from campus with a sneak peek at the
show and what Opportunity Village does
in the community Lauren it's been here
for so long
yes and it has
a great impact on the people that OV
serves we're going to get into that
first we're going to get into that as
well but first up I'm joined by Kim a
performer herself and finance director
Daryl Borges to talk more about the show
happening Thursday okay so what can
people expect for this free ovation
so you'll see dancing you'll see our
theater group you'll see our musicians
as well there's going to be a lot of fun
we have a special surprise as well I
can't say it because it's a surprise but
it'll be really cool so if you come out
it's a free show make sure you get out
here to Opportunity Village and check it
out and what would you say it's had an
impact on as far as people that OV
serves
so the impact the best thing is the
confidence levels that go up in our
performers and the people we serve here
I've seen people go that might be very
shy or maybe not speak so much and then
they get on stage and they get that
audience Applause and all of a sudden
you just see a whole new life the staff
here everybody that works here gets to
see our guys in a different light and
it's just amazing usually there's tears
there's all sorts of stuff it's it's so
fun and speaking of here Kim your tummy
used to be shy tell me about how OV has
helped you it got me out of my comfort
zone and be the person who I am today
and enough to be up on stage performing
A Whole New World a bunch of other stuff
why should people come on out because
it's a fun night out with your family
and you can see us perform
thank you so much like she said a fun
night out on Friday for free here at the
Buffalo and Russell campus Opportunity
Village first up you got the Art Walk 4
30 5 30 doors open and this the show
kicks off at six o'clock it'll be a
great night for now live at Opportunity
Village Lauren gritty eight news now
back to you guys thank you talent and
fun and you say hi to John langler when
you're out there too I'm going to MC
it'll be fun yes they're very important
to give support appreciate that Lauren
thank you